another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do at the foundation no  sending nigerian prince asks spam emails  to the church of the broken god email is  a vital communication tool to keep any  workplace running smoothly even the scp  foundation however like any great tool  it can also be used for evil or just a  bit of chaos dr bright decided to play a  prank and earn a bit of extra cash by  posing as a sentient machine in need of  help from the church of the broken gods  [Music]  us dollars to fight against the sarkites  for the glory of mccain send your  routing number and bank information asap  the church quickly wired the money and  were enraged when they learned they had  been duped they retaliated by leaving  flaming bags of dog poop on the front  steps of several foundation sites  needless to say dr bright has been  encouraged to find another outlet for  his more mischievous impulses they did  keep the money though